quale è stato il primo start difficile
ma arriva lo step più interessante che
chiamerò la pazza con la lira chitarra
ciao ragazzi e da tanto che volevo fare
questo video da tanto sia perché avrebbe
significato l'essere riuscito finalmente
a tagliare un traguardo e sia perché
ogni volta che taglia un traguardo mi
piace l'idea di poterlo condividere sono
dell'idea che se uno non condividere la
propria gioia è un pochino inutile
viverla in primis sono anni anni che io
e la mia famiglia
ormai lo sapete lavoriamo tutti quanti
insieme io da vini e gianmarco enrico da
gennaio del 2000 e 21 c'è anche graziana
che prima ancora di essere una mia amica
pagata come il più scritta ho pensato
molto perché in realtà mi piacerebbe
poter strumentalizzare e lucrare sulle
mie amicizie cosa che comunque io penso
che sia così non credo che nessuno di
noi mi ci voglia veramente bene anche
questi gatti vogliono bene solamente
perché io li pago dicevo prima ancora di
essere un'amica in realtà è una
grandissima professionista ha detto ciò
noi abbiamo iniziato a lavorare insieme
un tre anni fa calcolato una scommessa
totale perché non avevamo idea di dove
saremmo potuti andare dopo nemmeno un
anno avevamo fondato una società che li
aveva un bisogno di uno studio avevo
passato due anni ragazzi a cercarlo
infatti a breve vi racconterò anche
quali sono stati un pochino le
difficoltà ci sono due racconti che
secondo me sono al limite dell'assurdo
però finalmente siamo riusciti a trovare
uno studio il motivo anche per cui
ultimamente siamo tanto tanto impegnati
è anche legato al fatto che lo stiamo
arredandolo stiamo ristrutturando stiamo
trasformando una stanza in particolare
in una roba che non vedo l'ora di farvi
vedere perché è pazzesco chi mi segue su
instagram già avrà visto i lavori che
abbiamo messo in piedi nel trasformare
completamente questo spazio questo non
ufficio porterà un sacco di novità
migliorare i format e vi piacciono
vogliono lo stesso tempo metterne di
nuovi che avevamo sempre in mente non
c'era mai il posto giusto nel quale
potete fare finalmente questo posto ce
l'abbiamo in una zona meravigliosa una
zona che è molto legata a tutti quanti
noi ton e aggraziata che è de napoli
però insomma sarà legata anche alle
c'era le diamo a forza un posto
bellissimo è grande e più di quanto noi
potessimo pensare ed araba che hanno
fatto anche ragionare sul fatto che
spesso bisogna che cazzo del nordic
dicevo spesso bisogna passare un pochino
di difficoltà che a volte queste
difficoltà sono solamente delle
benedizioni mascherate perché se
avessimo preso gli altri due uffici
molto probabilmente non avremmo mai
trovato questo che è superiore al loro
di gran lunga vorrei dire a tutte quante
le persone che magari stanno cercando di
iniziare una propria attività che
vorrebbero trovare uno spazio nel quale
poter lavorare perché magari a casa non
ce la fanno e magari hanno anche ha
disponibilità economiche vogliono
investire dei soldi per riuscire un
proprio spazio che state facendo la cosa
giusta che non dovete mollare e che
arriverà assolutamente la soluzione un
pochino come l'amore non arriva mai
quando lo share che arriva una certa e
per tranquillizzarvi su questo voglio
condividerli al volo queste due storie
di cui vi sto parlando una è legata al
momento della nostra vita nel quale
abbiamo pensato veramente di non esser
degli perché avevamo trovato uno ormai
eravamo distrutti a pezzi non riusciamo
più a capire dove andare di non andare
se saremmo mai riusciti veramente a
trovare uno spazio che non fosse casa
mia
vi giuro io sono arrivato a un certo
punto a odiarli vedevo ovunque mi
girassi ospiti indesiderati la mia
famiglia con le loro cassine di caffè
che lasciavano in giro io non bevo caffè
quindi immaginate di quanto meno dei var
cura vedere quelle pazzini di caffè di
merda che continua a vedere perché
finché non andremo interno questo
ufficio purtroppo casa mia sono le norme
la soglia di terzini di caffè e anche
vederli in generale nella loro presenza
quindi finalmente l'anno tra d'ufficio
avevo detto ragazzi va benissimo
qualsiasi cosa per abbastanza spazioso
ero in una zona che lui mi faceva
impazzire ma tutto pur di andare a dire
al cazzo e mentre eravamo fare la
proposta alla fine ci ha superati un
notaio e lì il primo pensiero è stato
per i non saremo mai un notaio non
potremmo mai dare le stesse sicurezze a
qualcuno che magari può dare un notaio
quindi il lavoro del fare video sul web
verrà sempre visto come un lavoro di
serie b rispetto a quelli che sono i più
famosi
toccato un dentista e compagnia bella
quella lì è stato il primo stato
difficile ma arriva lo step più
interessante che chiamerò la pazza con
la lira chitarra avevano trovato un
ufficio ragazzi amore a prima vista ed è
quell amore che tu pensi che non
riusciremo a trovare perché cavolo quel
posto è perfetto la zona ottima il
taglio del locale stupendo ragazzi tutta
una roba di open space su più livelli
varie stanze questo posto prima però era
una scuola di musica che purtroppo per
via del copit ha subito un sacco di
problemi il vero problema però di questa
scuola di musica non era tanto il fatto
che insegna se musica era la
proprietaria una donna in affitto amante
della lira chitarra che inizialmente chi
cazzo è popolarità chitarra poi abbiamo
scoperto volerci spillare 300 euro in
più di quello che lei pagava per quel
locale le voleva che entrassimo in
subaffitto quindi lei voleva già a fare
la proprietaria da questo posto che li
lasciassimo una stanza spaziosissima per
lei moda poter continuare a fare delle
sue lezioni l'era chitarra che in primis
che cazzo fa lezioni lira chitarra in
italia abbiamo trattato ha detto senti
sia va bene tutto però non è che siano
proprio venuti qui con la vaselina
quindi ha detto va bene ri possa
abbassare il subaffitto però mi dovreste
lasciare un'altra stanza e poi un'altra
stanza cioè tendenzialmente a un certo
punto potevamo lasciare tutto quanto un
ufficio in condivisione pagando però noi
la cosa più triste per me è stato
rendermi conto per questa tizia non si è
mai resa conto delle pretese che
accampavano i nostri confronti ma
soprattutto è la tranquillità con la
quale pensava di poter spillarci soldi
per poter stare ovunque subito questa
esperienza più quella precedente che mi
hanno veramente fatto pensare a un certo
punto che non saremmo mai più riusciti a
trovare un ufficio mai più saremmo
riusciti a fare tutte quelle cose che
avevo in mente finché non è arrivato
questo il migliore abbiamo mai visto
ma sto assolutamente supermicro unico
anche un'altra cosa
due piani a stanze per tutti stanze per
farci 2000 cose apre la possibilità di
vedere qualche cosa e non vedo l'ora in
realtà di confezionare un bel bel video
di presentazione all'interno di questo
canale perché a partire da settembre
lavoreremo a delle nuove idee ma a breve
prima dell'estate
partiremo un progetto segreto per questo
mettendo in piedi un set che in italia
s'è mai visto io non vedo l'ora di
poterlo condividere con voi che anzi
ringrazio voi e voi i miei vuoi
ringrazio familiari perché insieme
stiamo creando un qualcosa che per me è
super importante e che va oltre
qualsiasi tipo di immaginazione che
potesse avere su quello che potesse
essere il mio futuro il futuro di questa
società è il futuro che la mia famiglia
ma il nostro futuro in generale perché
avere delle persone che ti sostengono in
maniera così forte un pochino come avere
altri alleati a bordo della nave è un
pochino sta cercando di comandare
all'interno di un mare che ti sembra di
non conoscere mai abbastanza vorrei
tanto far vedere come l'ufficio vuoto
vorrei farvi vedere il progetto al quale
stiamo lavorando perché vi giuro mi
stanno arrivando di prova a casa che la
prima che volevo fare era prende il
telefono e condividerli con voi ma devo
riuscire a resistere
devo aspettare devo essere paziente per
poterlo condividere al meglio sono
tantissime le cose che vorrei farvi
vedere altre che non vorrei farvi vedere
tipo livelli di stress che sono riuscito
a raggiungere il fatto che tutti ci
dicevano ma tranquilli con la pandemia
sarà facilissimo trovare un posto vorrei
farvi vedere tutte le tazzine di caffè
che sono all'interno di questa casa ma
le terrò per me le terrò come piccola
batteria di rancore che mi porterà
avanti nell'odio totale della mia
famiglia ed è uno dei motivi che mi
hanno spinto anche ad abolire il caffè
all'interno del mio ufficio tutte quante
le persone che vorranno qui lo dico per
la prima volta darsi una botta di vita
si potranno fare una siringa di aria
nelle vene e combattere tra la vita e la
morte augurateci in bocca al lupo se
volete perché tutte quante le energie
positive ci danno una mano enorme sono
cercano di capire come arredarlo anzi se
venite su instagram e mi date una mano
con dei messaggi privati quando siamo in
ufficio e magari condividiamo con voi
qualche cosa noi aiutereste tantissimo
un'altra se ci potrebbe dare una mano
veramente di cuore è iscrivere con
questo canale so che può essere
ma sapere che non siamo soli è una cosa
grande perché tanti chicchi di sabbia ad
una spiaggia varietà e tanti chicchi di
caffè fanno una tazzina quindi non
iscrivetevi gentilmente attivati inoltre
la campania delle notifiche che se ci
date la testa potrebbe sembrare una
tazzina di caffè al contrario di
cliccateci sopra per romperla insieme a
me è un modo per rimanere aggiornati
nello stesso tempo vi invito anche in
questo periodo preciso se vi va a
seguirci su instagram perché lì è il
posto all'interno del quale stiamo
riuscendo un pochino a fare un racconto
spizzichi e bocconi di quello che stiamo
creando all'interno di questo ufficio
non mi stanno facendo vedere tutto
armato mostreremo ogni singolo pertugio
di quel posto e vi garantisco che non ci
sarà mezzo centimetro quadro coperto
dalla tazzina di caffè
[Musica]